what's up guys I'm calling for the score
eSports you know when we talk about eras
in counter-strike they're often defined
by the teams that dominated them think
ninjas in pyjamas at the beginning of
csgo SK luminosity a few years ago and
now faze clan
maybe but which one is the ultimate
Counter Strike global Offensive roster
now before you hit the comment section
because I know you're dying to hear me
out and take a look at our criteria we
evaluated these teams partly on major
finishes top for consistency and yes how
they help define the era they played in
so without further ado sit back hit that
subscribe button and get ready because
this is the top ten rosters in csgo
history kicking off our list at number
10 is faze clans star-studded lineup
with superstar players in olofmeister
and Nikko a world class operand Guardian
and experienced players in Kerrigan and
rein phase is easily one of the most
impressive rosters at least on paper and
this kind of a band of rocks to us and
we're here to rule the world our typical
super team to compare to
I don't know Golden State Warriors if I
am at my peak oh my commitment despite a
shaky start at their first event this
lineup rebounded with ease placing top 4
in 11 out of 13 tournaments including 7
Grand Finals appearances and 3 first
place finishes faze clan might have lost
a cloud 9 in a nail-biting major grand
final but you can't argue against this
team's consistency at number 9 we've got
a fanatic lineup that featured the
original Swedish powerhouse in
olofmeister JW flusher Crim's and
newfound addition Denis from November
2015 to August of 2016
after a dominant run in the early fnatic
era the sudden departure of pronax an
edition of Denis left many fans
confused and baffled but the roster move
changed nothing as fnatic picked up
right where they left off
continuing their reign as CS goes best
team what's crazy about the success of
the new fnatic lineup it feels like it's
really made us actually kind of take
greatness for granted because already
this is clearly one of the best csgo
teams we've ever seen with Dennis on
board they made it to six grand finals
winning five back-to-back titles and
placing outside of the top four only
once in ten tournaments and number eight
on our list is the Navi lineup that
featured the likes of Zeus seized
Guardian Edward and flaming at a time
when csgo was arguably at its peak with
teams like fnatic luminosity and envious
na'vi were a model of consistency
routinely placing at the top of the
leaderboards the thing with Navi is
there's such a solid team really
structured and they will always as
foreign points out a number of times
they never get blown out of games
they've already accomplished so much
making it to the final of the last major
winning so many small tournaments so
many top for so many top eight finishes
this has been a very very consistent and
now it's all on shroud he has 17 seconds
and he goes for the fighting goes down
and now we are gonna witness 1648 it's
all on device one versus two he's behind
this watch while you get sprayed down
and now we're gonna make it 16 to 8 here
out of 27 premier events Navi made 13
grand final appearances 19 top four
finishes and won five titles hailing
from Denmark this roster of Dupree
device zip excursion B and Carrigan made
their presence known in the scene with
some dominant wins early on against some
of CS goes desk
here in Kerrigan it's a 200-ton curve
killer left left and he's coming plate
kick target down wait wait wait pistol
down meant they take it although they
were often known for falling short in
the tournament's that mattered the most
it was this team's incredible
consistency throughout their two-year
tenure that landed them on this list
during the run as Dignitas TSM and
Astralis the Danes boasted an incredible
streak of 21 top four finishes 9 grand
finals and won five championship titles
in that time span Wow number six on this
list is the next iteration of a straw
--less that previous Danish roster of
device Dupree Cajun Pacific's and
Kerrigan
met with inconsistent placings starting
in mid-2016 Kerrigan was swapped out for
new igl glaive and things turned around
immediately second kill for head drops
cold Sarah I said on the broadcast on
TBS they shot the world because none of
us had you getting out of the group
special she'd only been in the team for
like three days
huge test for this new lineup for as
strong as they bring in claim and they
defeat SK you haven't seen that part of
its knowledge for a very long time the
change proved to have an immediate
impact for the Danish squad placing
inside the top four in 13 of their first
14 events and although Astralis only won
three titles one of them was the 2017
eleague major over polish legends virtus
pro champions S tronic at our number
five spot
we've got ldl-c / envious which featured
the likes of Shox and BK kioshima Smiths
and happy in an era that was dominated
by Sweden this French team was one of
the most consistent placing in the top
four in 12 out of 15 premier tournaments
and making nine Grand Finals appearances
topping it all off with a major win at
dreamhack winter 2014 spot
ldlc they pick it up get that bacon
Carly believe they're hunting each other
and it must be an unreal sensation
we'll stand up and recognize ldl-c in
their performance up until 2018 it felt
like our number four roster had been
together since the dawn of time sticking
with their Korra necks b ali pasha
biceps Tazz and neo virtus Pro were the
longest standing five-man roster in
cs:go history so this is a lineup that
has had the same five players for longer
than any other team in csgo even when
they've hit slumps even when they've hit
lows in the past like they currently at
the moment they found a way back out
with it I mean there's a famous line
that they said an interview once where
they said we don't change players we
change roles and that really has been
the dynamic within virtus Pro for the
last few years with multiple top four
finishes over the years and several
high-profile tournament wins including a
major championship in 2014
virtus Pro have easily solidified their
spot as one of the best teams to ever
play the game coming in at number three
we've got the counter-strike legends
ninjas in pyjamas boasting Swedish
superstars Forrest get right Freiburg
exists and for Flair in this team was a
force to be reckoned with having won an
unfathomable 87 land maps in a row nip
crushed the rest of the competition and
were uncontested for most of 2012 it was
very cool and surprising to see that
they actually can be so dominant in a
game and also that you were one of the
best player at the same time an IP
ninjas and pyjamas were the best team in
the world by far they won their first 87
straight maps in offline competitively
in online games they occasionally lost
but offline they were imperious they
were unbeatable
the ninjas would go on to post an
impressive 17 top four finishes followed
by three consecutive major grand final
appearances including a major wins
in our runner-up spot is none other than
the Brazilian super team of coldzera
fallen fur taco and FNX at a time where
the csgo scene was dominated by European
rosters no one could have predicted such
a meteoric rise from a roster that
hailed from Brazil but with an
up-and-coming superstar and called Zahra
and one of the best in-game leaders in
fallen this lineup was poised for
success luminosity is a team that
essentially is like the brainchild of
one person is the sky fallen fallen
basically is the godfather of Brazilian
CS in luminosity continues to lead the
way in terms of strategy itself it's
very unique because the best in-game
leaders in the world in Counter Strike
Club throughout all of history been from
Europe the idea that a South American
guy could actually be the best tactician
in the whole world there's actually like
a revolutionary excel after multiple
tournament wins and placing outside the
top for only three times throughout 2015
and 2016 this lineup became only the
second team ever to win back-to-back
majors in terms of winning a second
consecutive major did you just put that
into words what that means to achieve is
such an incredible feat this is Martyn
respective be honest we just get outside
of Brazil get outside our
families we got inside our house to try
to do something but I think we're doing
more than something we're building a
legacy coming in at number one is none
other than fanatic featuring the likes
of olofmeister JW flush Crim's and
pronax this roster absolutely dominated
the csgo scene during their reign from
June 2014 to November 2015
fnatic won 12 championships made 17
finals and reached the top four in 24 of
27 premier tournaments oh yeah and they
were also the first team to ever win
back-to-back majors how does it feel
just taught me do the feelings I've
always like to know you've set all these
records you're now the first team ever
to win three majors you've gone on
back-to-back how does that feel I'm not
gonna keep pushing it what you want to
say about the rest of your team and how
they played I don't know I don't have no
words I'm their feelings I have no right
now is undescribable I don't see well
guys that's our list and if your
favorite roster didn't make it well
there's always next major right thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button